if you're looking for ways to take your
shot be motivated by fear and always be
joyous then this video is for you
what I've been trying to build and what
I've been trying to do with my life
keeps me in terror I am deeply motivated
by fear it's it's so wonderfully weird I
was excited about taking a shot I look
at the world through a lens of comedy
right so my natural reaction is always
no matter when something happens and I
can't even help it it's why is that
funny
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believing I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out into
the world so let's get your motivation
to a 10 and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from being the son
of a school board administrator and
refrigerator repairman in Philadelphia
to being one of the most bankable stars
in Hollywood having grossed over 7.5
billion dollars in revenue from his
movies he's Will Smith and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success vol
3 enjoy
so let's kick things off with rule
number one focus on the people you know
I've always been really product oriented
you know it's like I want to win when I
do something I want to win I wanted to
be number one and I want to smash it and
I had a period I have a daughter and I
was over a 15 year old daughter and she
really she got me and shifted my focus
from product to people it took a couple
of years but as soon as I gotten knocked
off of product and started shifting to
people the whole world opened up for me
again and acting opened up in a whole
new way to not go into day one of a
movie trying to figure out what
everybody has to do so we win versus
opening up and every person's a new it's
a whole new world meaning the character
you play all the people you work with
both absolutely you know generally when
I went into a product when I went into a
meeting with a director my focus was can
this guy win
can this girl win and that it was a it
was a you know who's a pathology that
got broken for me a couple of years ago
and then releasing that and just wanting
to connect with people and wanting to
grow and wanted to get new ideas and
have new experiences that don't have to
have an outcome they just opened up a
whole new world for me and I fell in
love and then I couldn't imagine what
else I could do in acting that could add
so much to my life other than acting
moving on to rule number two take a shot
police officer hey don't get me stabbed
my voice always gotta be the bad guys
well when you were on Conan you were
asked to give your best description of
Brighton you said think of it is the
energy of training day Meets Lord of the
Rings yes which is a little bit baffling
but surprisingly accurate confident that
you could pull off this odd cocktail no
I wasn't confident at all but that's
what was exciting to me it's is so
wonderfully weird I was excited about
taking a shot the fact that it was so
strange you know as an artist it was it
was a fun to get out on that on that
limb and hoping it doesn't break under
your feet time for rule number three
always be joyous I look at the world
through a lens of comedy right so my
natural reaction is always no matter
when something happens and I can't even
help it it's why is that funny you know
so even at a Funeral I can't help but
think why that's funny you know so it's
it's extremely helpful for me just
psychologically that no matter what's
going on I can't keep my mind from
finding jokes dude so it's a it's a
beautiful way to stay joyous and
positive let's go to rule number four be
motivated by fear you get nervous or
afraid I live in complete terror you
know everything for me about this
business and a you know about what I've
been trying to build and what I've been
trying to do if my life keeps me in
terror
I am deeply motivated by fear I'm
surprised you say you you live in fear
how do you deal with that do you turn
somebody for advice do you meditate what
how do you get over that you know I'm
trying to to develop a more realistic
perspective of what this business is
yeah I told my mother this the
the other day she thought it was
hilarious I said when I was 15 years old
my first girlfriend cheated on me oh and
I remember making a decision that nobody
would ever cheat on me again
and the way I was going to do that is by
being the biggest actor on earth ah
right so is there's there's been this
weird psychology that I've always felt
like if my movies are number one my life
is gonna work out great huh you know and
up next rule number five always look
forward I've always been the type of
person who thought of I thought of
myself as resilient you know that I
could always make my way back being
stuck in the past is of it makes it
extremely difficult to find your way out
and future thinking for me has always
been the way to get over difficult times
to be able to look over the darkness to
a potential time of light very rarely do
I look backwards I'm always looking
forward time for rule number six be
yourself so both our kids are in showbiz
- is that worrying for you no you know
it's you know to me showbiz is not
separated from the rules of the universe
right so whether you're in show business
or you know you're selling cars or
you're farming you know you're not
you're not separate from the laws of the
universe and all of the rules are the
same everywhere so for you know for from
my children the most important thing is
that they be encouraged to fully and
thoroughly be themselves no matter what
and when you when you have yourself and
you're thorough and confident in who you
are you can survive anywhere on - rule
number seven
experiment right goes out to 190
countries hundreds of millions of people
see it but it's not in theaters so for
two artists what is the unique
satisfaction of this you know so for me
it's really experimental what I learned
when Independence Day came out so I was
I had been doing The Fresh Prince and
that Friday before Independence Day came
out everybody will will will that Monday
was the first time that anybody ever
called me mr. Smith right so there's
something about that big screen that
NASA blockbuster that does something
inside of people emotionally so I'm
curious as to see because Netflix is
doing all of the other stuff you know
it's exactly the same production process
to a promotion everything is exactly the
same you would do for a gigantic
blockbuster and the question is will the
emotional resonance the sort of
nostalgic residue a year two years three
years from now still be there with
people not experiencing it in the
overwhelming fashion of the cinema so
you're just this is an experiment and we
see how it works let's see how it goes
yeah but it's definitely the future
next up rule number eight have a strong
y-you know I got the call from Ridley
and he said he said I've got a gift for
you and he he sent me a concussion and
you know I read it immediately and I
remember thinking that this ain't no
damn gift like I'm a football dad yeah
for for me it was a beautiful screenplay
but it opened up a huge conflict for me
did you know about about what had
happened before did you know the story a
little bit
vaguely okay really vaguely I I knew you
know my son play football for for four
years and during that time I had never
heard about the the concussion issue
okay at all I don't loca so you know it
was part of what really inspired me and
made me wanna to to do the the film
forced me to to have to do the film is
because as a parent I had no idea I had
no idea that there was a an issue with
his repetitive head trauma right in in
football man so it was a it was a quite
a revelation let's go to rule number
nine put positive energy in the world
for me a personal confrontation with
death made me see the value of time and
the fact that the only elixir is love
you know so the the time that you spend
has got to be in preparing yourself and
giving and receiving the most about a
love you can you know my mission is to
improve lives so I want to do things
that put positivity and positive energy
and love into the world and finally rule
number ten before we get to the bonuses
have fun so I'm gonna put on this orc
mask because I can't walk the floor
comic-con as me and out in the middle
with everybody I think I'm with people
alright so now I feel sorry for Joel
all these things when we go out of
public I'll go kill somebody so let's go
and I never get to do this this is gonna
be grandma get to walk around
[Music]
it's hard to see and is hard to breathe
but almost soldiers I don't need neither
water than thing I'm all for hope our
love
[Music]
so thank you guys so much for watching
my favorite rule is number three always
be joyous and I was actually surprised
by that clip I didn't expect that to be
my favorite and I don't know about the
part about laughing at funerals and
finding jokes but I think for me I often
get comments of people saying what drugs
are you on how are you always so
positive and I just focus on the good
things I just focus on being joyous I
focus on the things that I have in my
life that I'm super grateful for and I
think I guess in general entrepreneurs I
think are optimistic but I don't know I
think when you understand what you stand
for you know I believe and believe and I
wake up most days just feeling good
about life and wanted to create
something better for myself and the
people around me I don't really have
that many bad days I think more bad
moments and I just really resonated with
the always be joyous point theme I want
you guys to have a little more joy as
well so that was my favorite rule number
three I'd love to know do you guys agree
with me is number three the best rule or
is there one that you guys like Marv
leave that down the comments below I'd
love to hear from you
now I made this video because you guys
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
poke file next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote on
the request line I also want to give a
quick charter to surge wisdom thank you
so much man for picking up a copy of my
book your one word I'm doing all of
those chapter by chapter book reviews on
your channel I really really appreciate
it man
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
the idea of trying not to fail I think
it's like that is that that is the
killer for an actor of trying not to
fail because the camera feels that thing
it feels that you're uncertain and not
sure it's like let it rip like fail hard
and fail Wow what is the notion of
collateral Beauty to you as a theme as
an idea you know the I the the concept
that there's in your in your worst of
times there's this one little thread of
beauty and if you can just stay
conscious and aware enough and grab onto
that little thread it is the thread that
leads you out of the labyrinth of your
suffering you know to be able to to hang
on to the beauty long enough to find
your way back to to you know the warmth
of love and you know the beauty of the
light
[Applause]
I just love that thing in in somebody's
face like that like that's the reason to
make entertainment right raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people need passion
and not one drop of most self-worth
depends on Europe that's supposed to
mean I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or absolutely infested
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten gross a
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link the description
for details